[Music]
so you know any migration is always
complicated because migrations aren't a
thing that we do as a business right
when you start a technology business
your goal isn't to do a migration so
it's a rare occurrence in anyone's lives
and it's always it always brings with it
anxiety and you know a lack of
understanding of what we need to do to
really be able to push this ball forward
so we're not here to tell you about what
technologies to pick how to avoid that
weird gke load balancer issue that
happens every now and then but rather
you know if you're an engineer here if
you're a manager here if you're a leader
here each one of you today owns a piece
of your business right you're no longer
just doing work you actually own a piece
of your business so our goal here is to
teach you as an owner of that piece of
the business what can you do to plan and
execute effectively on the piece that
you own and also how you are able to
collaborate better so that as an
organization you know you can manage
something that can be pretty large and
complex and a fair amount of unknowns so
the way we're gonna do it is give a
little bit of information about who the
plate key players were here right well
Google bought to the table and what who
unity is and we're gonna talk about the
why the vision was our partnership and
what was the goals of what we were
trying to achieve here and then finally
we're gonna give you details about the
approach what we did how we did it what
worked for us what didn't work for us
and hopefully you know takeaways that
you can walk away with that'll help you
make your next migration a lot easier so
as we start you know I just wanted to
quickly talk about Google professional
services organization there might be
some other folks in the room who were
working with your Tam's or you know your
PR team on the ground if not you know
PSS mission is to help customers get the
most out of Google cloud and basically
we go to market in three separate
pillars we have our consulting on
migration services we have our Technical
Account Manager so the Kam's which you
know some of you are working with
already and
we have our training and certification
so this three together forms our Google
cloud professional services and we our
aim is to work almost as an extension of
your team and get all the feedback back
over to our product and engineering so
as we start we'll talk about the unity
and Google partnership first
yeah so who is unity I'm I'm hoping a
fair amount of you know us but I'll
cover it anyway you know we're the
world's most popular CD 3d content
creation system and we we started with
games will be kinda expanded into the 3d
content creation space but really what
we are is a complete game creation
platform right are our pillars of create
operate and monetize allow game
developers to build a business because
today game development is not just about
game building games but you have to
build a viable business around it and
game developers what they do best is
build games so unities goal is to take
away the rest of it and make it really
easy for them to build a viable business
around their games now we've been in
play for a while and we were wildly
popular in many spaces we've we've had
over twenty nine billion installs with
some kind of unity experience in it
within just the last 12 months you know
60% of all AR and VR content today is
powered by unity and over 50% of all new
mobile games are today build on unity so
and then the Unity Google cloud
partnership yes so you know as you can
see here already sporting it on my
jacket so we unity and Google cloud also
partnered together on this thing called
the connected games this the whole point
of connected games is to connect players
to each other and players to developers
as well and you know basically provide a
more enriching experience to game
players so Google cloud and unity
specifically are partnering on that
again as you can see we have a lot of
initiatives with unity going across
across the company but this is something
we are very very specific on Google
cloud and unity and if you need more
information you can read up on connected
games on the unity blog alright so as we
start you know thank do you want to give
an overview of how your
yes so one of the unique challenges that
we had was that our team is extremely
global unity today is in over 30 offices
in over 22 countries worldwide you know
we have close to 10 key locations across
the globe so you know a company that is
built like this cannot operate in a
extremely top-down structure so we focus
very heavily on collaboration and
empowerment and I'm bringing this up
because you know as you're starting out
on your migration it's very important
for you to know how your organization's
structured this actually plays a very
important part in how you're gonna plan
and how you're gonna execute on the
migration so for us this was a unique
challenge that I wanted to highlight
well it's really cool and you need a
site to be globally distributed it
becomes really a big challenge when you
are a services arm and you're trying to
achieve the migration so we started
thinking about you know from the Google
PSO side how do we map a team to you
know address unit is global and
distributed nature of business so we
started with teams in San Francisco
Seattle in Austin in the Americas we
quickly realized that we have to scale
up our team in the e Mia's across
Stockholm and Helsinki where one of
their key business units are we also had
a team out there in London and as you
can see in the previous slide unity does
have a office in Shanghai China so
Google doesn't have a peer so team in
China so to map to that in the same time
zone you know we had to create a we had
to have a team in Singapore which was in
the same time zone
now this is really important because you
know local timezone interaction during a
tight schedule and a timeline is really
important and having that local support
in where you are you know where where
the migration is happening this is
really that's why we went with this
global in you know nature of the team
also sometimes when issues come up we
cannot you know the teams cannot wait
for eight hours for us to wake up and
actually answer to get their questions
answered so removing the local blockers
was like removing blockers in local time
is a really really important thing the
third thing is you know the camps across
the globe we're kind of always keeping a
tab on
how the migration was going on so again
we had danced in all the regions that we
saw alright so you know just when we try
to summarize the whole migration journey
in one slide it's really really
difficult because you know there are as
being said so many business units across
so many cities we again there was a very
tight timeline the migration has to be
completed within a within 2018 so we try
to represent the whole journey in you
know at least one slide the important
thing that I want to kind of draw your
attention is if you see the red box
there which says the pre migration and
then the green box which is the
migration this is really important you
know as van could kind of agree - we
spent a lot of time building out the
foundation in the first three months now
there were concerns are we moving fast
enough our applications coming onto
cloud it and we basically as the join
team together we had to push back and
say that it's really really important to
set up your foundation first you need to
set up your network your I am your
security controls and what we saw is
because we spend three dedicated months
in the first phase of the migration the
phase zero and the phase one the next
six months were highly highly
accelerated so if you are embarking on
an migration or you know you're just
about to kind of start a migration in
phase one please do build your
foundations properly because I think if
you do that I think it's just easier to
bring the applications and the workloads
later in the remaining half of this yeah
like this plan at the beginning looks
counterintuitive right because in fact
when we went and pitched this what it
essentially looks like that we're
basically training for half the time on
a 8 month migration for what is a
extremely high scale set of services but
there was a plan behind it because when
the teams were ready to go they were
ready to really run with it we had made
sure to account for all of the major
blockers we're gonna cover this in more
detail about what we did within that pre
migration period that really set us up
but this point is so important that
we're gonna highlight it
few times through this presentation
there is a lot of value in taking the
time to prepare and one more thing you
know what kind of caught us off guard a
little bit last year was gdpr was the
hot thing and a lot of your cast you
know if you're a customer you've been
like hit with the DD fair requirements
so you know again it goes back to the
foundation if you set the foundation
right I think's getting compliant on
many of these standards are pretty much
easy later on so we also did spend a
bunch of time on the gdpr part because
that was like literally the time when
everybody had to be gdpr compliant so
you know given such and I see this
across all the customers more so for a
very very tech-savvy digital native
customer like unity is they are pushing
our products and our platform to the
boundary like you know veng said 29
billion downloads there are millions of
transactions even billions like you know
in the minute and a per second so this
you know it's a very intense application
stack that they have so as part of that
there were many many things that came up
you know the TAM team and the PSO team
overall worked very closely with our
engineering and product teams to
actually unlock a bunch of features gke
shared VPC was kind of gwen GA at the
time cloud composer gke plywood cluster
these were absolutely a major blocker to
the migration and you know all kudos to
our product teams who were able to kind
of get those products to GA during the
migration and you know we were able to
move all the workloads over but there is
always like newer things coming down the
pipe as you saw you know i think i just
saw an announcement around traffic
director so you know it was really
important and I think all thanks to the
unity team we said that when we have
like a 10 feature request it's really
important to prioritize those feature
requests like what are the things that
will block the migration what are the
things which are kind of nice to have
that in the next six months if they go
GA that will be fine and what are the
things that you'd need one year down the
line and I think that collaboration with
the unity team work really well they
said you know the private gk cluster and
the shared VPC were really really
creative
items that needed to be in the migration
with this light also highlights really
is the fact that a lot of you are gonna
think of your migration as your burden
to carry but it's not it's a partnership
wait there is a there is a team of
people out there that don't just sell
this product but they're proud of this
product they wanna they want to learn
more about it they want to know what you
need and what you're missing they want
to come to the table and what it does
for you is it actually makes it a lot
easier for you to understand the insides
of the product to for us we really
focused on understanding not just how
the product worked but also what didn't
work for the product because it wasn't
important for us to pick it if it worked
perfectly but rather just like any
business today what's down the road map
what can we use today how do we set it
up so that we can work around any
potential issues and that doesn't happen
in a silo so the Google in any
partnership for any migration requires
that you actually invest the time as
part of your primary pre migration
strategy to really learn with the team
about what they have and how it works so
you know if you look across the
different unity business units across
the stack they're using a lot of
products right now you know when even
after the migration was complete newer
work streams are getting kicked in I
think 2018 correct me if I'm wrong was a
focus was really really on kind of
lifting shift move the workloads over to
GCP 2019 is more around you know
enhancing the data looking at ml use
cases so I would say last year was very
very focused when we did the migration
around compute storage networking all
the core foundations of the stack in
2019 again as I said the story only
starts after the migration when the
workloads actually come over so this
year we are actually working with unity
to kind of enhance that and spend our
time in the data and m/l space and once
again this was not a generic decision
that we took by looking at the
technologies we looked deeply within our
architecture and evaluated per situation
what makes sense to take over it became
very quickly clear to us that compute
was a central piece of our technology so
it wasn't enough that we just lift and
shift it we had to look at google manage
technologies and figure out what we
could use there in order for us to scale
on the other hand you know unity has
always been very very passionate about
data and about machine learning but
those were things that were very
customized within unity to date so in
that case it didn't actually make sense
for us to try to bring it over and
within the Google set up because the
reorg attack sure would be too much for
us to handle at the same time as a
migration so we looked at each piece
individually to make a decision about
how we had to move it over so why was
this important thing can you give an
example so I don't know if any of you
know this game
apex legends but once we finish the
migration over you know we had our multi
play platform now able to support
workloads through GCP and when apex
launched it was a huge launch for those
of you that remember it you know they
had over 1 million players within the
first couple of days you know today they
have over 50 million players in and out
of the game 2.3 million simultaneously
right and this is around the world so at
peak times were actually using 230,000
compute coders I mean I'm pretty sure
we've maxed out the Google quota
multiple times through this process but
it was possible to really quickly launch
this and scale it because the backing
and the foundation of GCP and the way
that we architected it was solid yeah
this is really important like Google
cloud will scale up and you know it will
scale up to handle such launches but
again because we kind of set up the
networking and the I am and the security
in a way collaboration with the unit iam
that just adding course was relatively
like the easier part of the problem once
we set up the foundation Danny and we
keep harping on that point because I
think both Fermi and Wang that is really
close to our heart that we spend that
time in the first quarter so let's dig
really deep into how we actually plan
this migration so here's the background
right now we talked about the
partnership the partnership was not just
a PR spiel that somme and I came up with
because our companies told us you the
partnership is important here to mention
because we actually had to take this
vision not just who the executives about
the importance of this part
but you actually have to do that for
each one of your teams you cannot expect
your team's to believe and move
independently on this on a mic on
something as key as a migration unless
you explain to them the vision the goals
and the business value and if you're not
doing that with your teams then you're
not empowering them to be part of the
business so when we set up this
partnership we took that to the teams
and we empowered them by explaining the
problem and after that we got out of the
way right we empowered them with the
problem and asked them to come up with
the right solution we told them all of
the business needs the deadlines what
happens if we go over X versus Y how is
spend affect it through this year we
laid it out for the teams and when I say
teams I don't just mean the directors I
mean every engineer every lead had
access to this information and was
encouraged to know about it when you do
that now you have teams that are truly
bought in because they're aligned with
that vision and then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy the second
thing we did was we use this as an
opportunity for evaluation and refresh
one of the things that you hear a lot in
the industry is lift and shift or
transformation right and it becomes this
binary thing that you're solving for it
you're either taking all of your crap
that you have in your house and moving
it over or you're just scrapping it
entirely and just buying everything new
but that's not really true is it right
every situation is unique you have to
look at every scenario and evaluate
using the guidelines and the goals that
you've outlined as part of the
empowerment to understand what makes
sense so for example in our case you
know we had been using our own
kubernetes stack but we took the time to
evaluate gke and we realized the value
that it was gonna bring because what we
had was essentially many many sets of
isolated kubernetes clusters but what
gka allowed us to do was really
centralize that system and it actually
fundamentally changed how we operate as
an organization today instead of having
every team kind of figure out their own
gke we've centralized these things back
to teams that are dedicated to it as in
their ex they are experts in gke
they centralize the modules they roll
out the clusters we use different models
to help other teams scale but when we
made that decision it actually helped us
move faster we did the same thing with
logging - we had an in-house stack that
we had always been a little troubled by
because it wasn't super effective when
we looked at stackdriver we evaluated
the advantages we get in terms of you
know gained people back into the
workforce because they don't have to
worry about managing an in-house stack
versus what it would cost us to run it
these are real things these are
practical things that each team should
not be looking at it shouldn't just be
happening at the executive level on the
flip side you know we have a highly
customized data pipeline and that was
not something that we wanted to take to
dance we evaluated pub/sub and/or our
evaluation was that we're gonna move it
over or we're gonna evaluate how to move
it over next year so that one we
actually knew because we've done the
math behind it that it made more sense
for us to take asses now one of the
things that was to our advantage was we
were a distributed architecture we've
kind of been very micro service mesh
from the beginning you know everything
that we do is API and message base so
essentially we already had a bunch of
independent layers that we could figure
out how to migrate them over now I call
this out because this work to our
advantage but there are technologies
that you're working on that may be a
monolith that may be multiple monoliths
or some version of the monolith and the
distributor architecture these are
important because you have to do your
own independent evaluation it's not just
enough to look outside and pick the
standard that everybody else is using
and then globally global teams again
we've talked about this before this was
a particularly unique problem for us
which is we're trying to do a migration
in a very short timeline with teams that
are across the world and how do we
coordinate that so what we did and I'm
gonna cover this in the next slide in
planning what we did essentially was
really kind of focus on the results
rather than the process right we focused
on empowering these teams so that they
could move on what they needed to
independently but we had to come up with
ways to be able to track the system and
finally and this was the toughest part
business continuity during the migration
there was no stopping for the business
we continued to work on
products and features and roll them out
we had no downtime while we migrated a
high scale system I mean we have two to
three billion users in and out of this
system every month we process you know
twenty thirty thousand events every
second and all of this is at low latency
you know in some cases the latency
requirements were so strong that we had
to pick data centers on both sides like
to so that we could route in under ten
milliseconds and we did all of that
without experiencing any downtime and
that I think think is another key point
that always comes up again from the PSO
side we always see like the customer
saying our our engineer is going to
build the next product or are they going
to focus on migration and because they
are both equally time taking and while
on one side you have to kind of make the
business go forward come up with the new
features you also have to finish this
migration so I think just the balance
that the unity team with a help on the
PSO side were able to create was really
really a you know that's one of the key
things why these things went well and we
were able to complete this within a
short timeframe and again for us it was
a practical decision because we looked
at the logistics of it if we're building
a feature what value do we get with
differing sections of the migration
versus what do we get from speeding up
the migration in certain aspects we
always went back to the basics we always
looked at the goals when we were trying
to solve these day-to-day tough problems
so migration planning we already covered
this but plan twice execute once I
cannot stress this enough
now what did it actually mean when we
when we did planning we started with the
very very basics we put the people into
quick labs in Coursera we gave them
access to you know online training that
they use to pick up at least the basics
of a new system because most of us were
actually unfamiliar with GCP to begin
with then we went into the next stage
which is now that we understand the
basics we started to work closely with
the Google teams to actually understand
certain technologies very very deeply
we've already identified things like gke
but it wasn't just enough that we looked
at the documentation so we would sit
down with the teams and walk them
through our use cases across the board
and explain how we
were planning to use it and what made
sense then we went even one more level
deeper at this point we had each of the
teams that owned pieces of the
architecture sit down for days on end
with the Google teams and the teams were
bringing their own experts based on
specific technologies that we wanted to
use wait if we wanted to do if you
needed a Postgres equivalent so cloudsql
they would bring those experts over if
we were evaluating pub/sub then we would
make sure we had a pub/sub expert there
and we would spend all day in a room
walking through the stack breaking it
down over and over digging into how
they're supposed to talk to each other
how to firewall rules work
how does access flow everything from
where do we set up the projects to which
services run on which cluster we tried
to lay as much out as possible the
advantage of doing this in a very
collaborative fashion as opposed to
having people go out and write documents
and review it over and over is that it
really sped up the time to get to the
ideal result so we actually focus a lot
on just bringing people together we
actually had people fly to different
offices we had local tans and this was
another big advantage of local teams
then this actually gave us time for
learning and exploration right so as I
mentioned we covered a lot of detailed
content with the teams once we've kind
of gotten to the point where we
understood what each team did had to do
we went the next level which was we
actually started doing cross team
dependencies so we would have teams sit
down together
we're known dependencies existed once
again in collaboration with Google who
talks through the details like okay how
do we manage latency here how do we
manage the data workloads that are going
to flow through at peak periods this
forces you to do a lot of research this
forces you to gather the right metrics
to understand your system better it's
not just enough for you to have the
basics everybody knows well how many
requests there is you know their service
deals with but you don't necessarily
know what your error rate is what your
peak loads look like what patterns your
traffic flows through how does it deal
with specific types of exceptions right
because when you move from one stack to
the other you're actually going to see a
change in where the errors are generated
because certain you know different
clouds handled resiliency differently so
we really focused on those aspects
now while the teams were off doing that
we were focusing on phase zero what is
phase zero compliance security sre
Network and developer tools so while the
engineering teams were off figuring out
how they could migrate we had actually
set off the phase zero teams which
really if you think about it this is
your foundation this is what creates the
right GCP foundation for you to use we
had these teams often running in
parallel setting up the actual
production stage and production
infrastructure so the the engineering
teams were off in sandboxes having these
detailed conversations and learning more
about the tech and in the meantime you
know security was coming up with how do
you set up the google groups to set up
the right access how do you do
editor versus read-only how do you do
billing access where do you give super
admin right how does sre get access to
systems across different bill
organizational units at your company
versus what you do for your own teams
within your own organizational unit we
also covered compliance you know gdpr
was a big one that we were dealing with
there's a lot of little nitty-gritty
that you figure out as you're digging
into it
for example GCP by default does geo
blocking of certain countries that are
embargo and these are pieces that you're
only gonna figure out when your
compliance team gets in there and ask
the right questions cuz that's what they
do at the same time network was a heavy
heavy focus we push bandwidth like crazy
so we definitely had the network team in
there not just looking at how they're
gonna use the existing set up but how we
can improve it and actually build a much
stronger foundation for what we knew we
were gonna scale in the next three to
four years now work streams in
dependencies so this is a tricky one to
talk through but I'm kind of I'm gonna
hand away my way through it and
hopefully you guys are gonna see because
this was actually a critical part of our
success what we focused on in this whole
pre-migration area was building out work
streams think of your work streams as
layers within your stack right at the
very basic you're probably gonna have
network then on top of that you're
probably gonna have kind of your
foundational pieces of how do you start
up the clusters then you're gonna have
the actual services that run between
them but the services are also layered
right you will have your back-end
services that are talking to the data
pipelines that are actually talking to a
middleware
that are talking to a pure front-end
service so there's all these layers that
you have now if you're able to neatly
draw them out so that they create these
parallel paths
well you've effectively done is one
you've identified work streams each of
these work streams is a cohesive unit
that can move independently your data
pipeline is different from your services
is different from your front-end the
other thing that you're going to end up
doing when you draw this out you're
gonna you're gonna have lines that
crossover between the work streams
those are your dependencies right so now
you know exactly who talks to whom
because you'll aim this out in charge
you know towards the end we had giant
charts that were you know that had a ton
of different work streams in them and so
we had we actually ended up creating
like work streams within work streams in
some cases but as it when you're doing a
migration as a company you have the
bandwidth you have the manpower to be
able to go take it and break it down so
what we did was each work stream that we
started with was a business unit and
then that business unit would go in and
break down their work stream into
further alaior x' but these layers were
very important one we always had
visibility into what the layers were and
where the dependencies lay to we never
ran into the issue of people not
understanding how the architecture was
flowing because this was always a great
reference point for us to be able to lay
back to finally tracking the milestones
so after we have this these work teams
and dependencies laid out it actually
led us track to milestones now I'm gonna
say this to you a little differently
because a lot of us when we're doing
this migration we're gonna focus on the
process and we're gonna focus on the
deadlines right that's that's natural
that's what we do but when we have a
global set of teams in our and our goal
was to empower them you know there was
no way for us to be able to pull it off
by saying hey this is the date you gotta
hit it by these are all the processes
that you have to follow so we kind of
flipped it on its head we focused on
milestones not status and we focused on
results not process so what that means
is every team was able to own a piece of
the work stream independently all we did
was create standard milestones that we
could track across these work streams
something as simple as your stage prod
being milestones or a security review
being a milestone like pick your mouth
stones right but they become standard
across the team's the second thing we
did was as we when we would collaborate
when we would review updates we never
focused on the status we focused on the
results right we focused on the
milestones so what have you achieved so
far and what are you going after next
how can we help you get there
where do the dependencies exist and how
can we help bring the collaboration
together what it did was it kind of
changed the framing of this whole
migration it became less of a process
and it became more of kind of a shared
goal that we were all going after the
other thing that was unique at least in
our situation was our teams use
different supporting stacks not
everybody is on the same you know
ticketing system not everybody is using
the same developer tools so once again
in that case you know how are we gonna
actually track to this like how are we
gonna know when an engineering team is
has finished X milestone because you
know how the traditional process grows
right you put everything into JIRA you
create this giant Gantt chart and then
everybody's just looking at it every
week going well we slipped by two days
here but that was not what we wanted to
do because again the focus was not the
Dettol and the focus was the shared
vision this goal so we actually took
that work in - believe it or not we
spent a week creating this tracker that
essentially took all these disparate
pieces of data and just kind of rolled
it up into a simple work stream based
progress and we shared that every week
across the board the executives they all
knew what was going on because it was a
very simple way to view it in fact I
think and I don't say that out loud
I believe Google liked our tracker so
much that it may be showing up but now
as a template for other migrations so if
you see one that looks kind of like a
work set of work streams that was us and
then finally you know the cadence for
the global teams now as I said you know
it's very hard to track these global
teams so we focused on the goals and the
results we we tried really hard to stay
away from the process so at the end of
the day this is kind of a very very high
level of what the work streams look like
right these cohorts are essentially big
milestones that each one of these people
own delivering and if you notice it was
possible
for them to be extremely parallel big
ones we even broke down into further
work streams and we had dependencies
tracked between them but the reason why
we could move on all of this in parallel
was because we focus on making these
work stream is as independent as
possible and I think the cohort was also
really like defining what goes in cohort
one and two and three that was really
also very important because it kind of
gave us a staggered approach and when we
go went live it wasn't like it's all or
nothing we went live with the first set
everything work well we went live with
the second one so I think that was
really really useful yeah and we're
actually going to talk about some of the
learnings now because we also stumbled
along the way there were things that we
learnt and they're kind of the nitty
gritty they're the practicalities of
when you try to do a migration so we'll
start with the don'ts because you always
want to know the don'ts first okay first
of all don't migrate all of your baggage
right but also don't my freaking out of
your maggots you got a pic think about
it like moving into a new apartment wait
when you move into a new apartment you
don't just take all those boxes that
have been sitting in your garage for
months or years but you also don't just
leave them in the house you want to go
through and clean up as you go so do
that be practical about it and more
importantly don't try to put a ton of
process around it your engineering teams
know these things they know where the
bag is practically can be moved versus
not just let the engineering teams be
empowered to do something like this too
don't build a snowflake if you have a
snowflake don't migrate the snowflake
we all have stacks especially if the
technology we're working on is a few
years old we all have these snowflakes
sitting around but the world has changed
so much is out there now Google
aggressively looks across and tries
tries to find these common patterns so
there are there are known best cloud
practices there are known application
patterns to follow use them this is
actually a great time for you to be able
to reinforce them wait if you you know
that there is a VM out there somewhere
that is open to the Internet and nobody
knows about you know there's that one
guy whose laptop has access to the
production infrastructure take the time
to clean it up right take the time to
put better practices in place
don't migrate the monolith now this is a
harder problem than just putting it up
as a point on a slide so when you're
looking at a monolith you know do your
best to apply this triangular pattern
pull out what you can that's safe what's
feasible and try to move that over it's
actually gonna have a two-fold result
one it's gonna make your monolith
smaller and easier to migrate but two
it's also gonna provide a proof of
concept for how to be able to scale to
bigger migrations right because you're
gonna pull out really really small
pieces you can start with simple things
like your config service or your
identity or just a connector to the
database separate out your database
doing the API and just move that over
now don't retain single points of
failure this one was especially
important for us for example I told you
we use network bandwidth like crazy so
when we were moving over to Google we
really button that we created multiple
points of failures and redundancies in
there that has actually allowed us in
recent times to deal with network
outages that we've seen that were either
that were on the third party side but
we've been able to deal with that
because we actually took the time to
evaluate our bandwidth understand it and
then put the right redundant and
redundancy in place we did the same
thing for kubernetes you know multi-zone
was always a great idea what that reason
is even better but multi zones always a
great idea
so we took the time to do that too and
finally don't reaaargh attack everything
right especially not your plumbing don't
try to move over to that brand-new
monitoring system while you're trying to
do the migration move parts over that
need to be migrated and deal with
everything as a separate initiative now
in some cases they may be tied together
in which case use your work streams and
dependencies to be able to separate them
out if you treat your developer tools as
an early work stream that has a
dependent that the later work streams
have a dependency on you're actually
gonna create a phased approach of how
we're doing things so like ven talked
about the very specific on the
technology side I want to talk about the
people and process side as well because
you know until all these three together
come together you won't have a
successful migration so the first key
dawn
in the only people process side is
please don't migrate in a vacuum
think about the downstream dependencies
think about you know what and other
teams downstream are going to be
impacted by this migration and please
involve all these cross-functional
stakeholders when you do so if you don't
do that it's like even though your
component is successfully migrated the
shared vision would not be met so you
know no migration in a vacuum I think
you know don't focus on deadlines I
think ven talked about it I'm not going
to go into the details I think you know
it should be shared goals it should be
talking about shared focus areas and you
know it everybody should treat feel as
part of the migration and you know just
saying I have to do it on by October
30th is you know that's not going to cut
it because you have to take everybody
along another thing which was important
is you know the lifting shift versus
transformation I think there is I think
what the point we are trying to make is
there is no one correct answer some of
your components will be lifting shift it
makes sense to just take what you're
running and just move it to GCP versus
some you should take the you know option
that you are doing a migration why don't
you transform so you know each work
stream should be treated very
differently each component should be
different treated and evaluated
differently across all the work streams
I think there is no mandate that
everything needs to be either lift and
shift or transform I think the unit is
migration was a very good example of a
mix of both these approaches where it
made sense we lived in you know we had a
lift and ship where it made sense we
actually looked at a transformation
approach and then you know just don't
assume that planning leads to success
while planning is really important but
following up and executing and on it is
really really important and iterate on
the plan and in every migration that we
are seeing there are unknown blockers
that will crop up there will be churn in
terms of folks joining the team people
go so you know you have to keep
iterating on the plan because if you
don't eat rate on the plan and you just
stick to something that you planned six
months back it's always you know that's
not setting up for success so that is a
real
we don't in terms of like from a process
perspective so now what to do from the
technology side we've covered phase zero
in detail it is very important to
establish a solid gcp foundation because
here's the thing to remember the
migrations not the end of the journey
it's the beginning of it you are tying
yourself to a technology for a long
period of time hopefully hopefully
migration is not what you do as a
company and when you're doing that you
want the foundation to be extremely
solid the more debt you accumulate the
harder it will be going forward now some
kinds of debt are isolated and you can
actually make calls on them but
foundational debt is different if your
access controls are not in place when
five people are in the system it is
going to be a lot harder to do it when
300 or 3,000 people are gonna be in the
system if you were Network firewalls
aren't in place to segregate the
environments when there's no services in
there it's not gonna happen when there's
thousands of services in there and the
what also changes is the manpower needed
to do it at a later time exponentially
goes up too so it is very very important
that you establish this foundation
automate everything this is the key part
so we actually took this time to
automate everything that we found that
was manual and we actually had it in
three different styles so we had
everything was infrastructure as code
right that was kind of the the principle
that we aligned on that we were gonna do
but also when we were looking at
infrastructure and we realized all
infrastructure was being written as code
we centralized a lot of the pieces that
we knew were in use across multiple
parts of the company and we offered them
as infrastructure as a service or
infrastructure as a framework and what
infrastructure is a framework I'm
assuming all of you know infrastructure
as a service but what infrastructure as
a framework does is it actually takes
some of the burden of maintaining the
service and passes that on to the user
of that service and this works really
well for internal teams so it's a good
example you know we had many many uses
of [ __ ] and they were all isolated
they've been some of them were manually
set up some of them were set up in
different kinds of automation they all
had different configuration different
use case
but we spent the time to have a single
team actually pick up all of that
understand from each of the users what
they were trying to do take it all back
and rewrite it as a centralized module
now this module is a lot better
maintained because we actually use
automation to not just deploy and run it
but we also use automation to test it we
have a team that's dedicated to continue
to improve it which means that you don't
fall behind on versions you don't fall
behind on new functionality you don't
have bad bugs sitting around in your
system but also it didn't make sense for
a team like this to try to run every
database in the company you're just
creating a just an unhealthy central
dependency so we offered it as a
framework l we maintain the module we
improve it you go use it you own the
cluster that it runs on it also passes
the ball a little bit of making sure
everybody knows how to run
infrastructure right most of us today
understand the concept of you build it
you run it you own it in fact a unity we
have this joke that says you know you
build it you run it you pay for it
because our engineering teams actually
know what it takes to actually spit in
terms of spend for their services to run
they use that to continuously optimize
their services but and this is the kind
of empowerment do you want to make sure
that you offer to your team's minimize
technical debt now we've talked about
technical debt quite a bit specifically
you know which you want to look at it's
just old debt that's sitting around
that's gonna severely hamper you in one
of our cases we had a old highly
customized load balancer that had been
written in-house that was sitting on a
system and when we looked at gke we knew
that we could really check the system a
little bit and actually get rid of this
custom load balancer so we took the time
to do it
so minimize techno tech Nicole that were
feasible especially fundamental
technical debt don't take it with you
iterate and learn so the way the work
streams were set up they were actually
set up in increasing levels of
complexity and collaboration so the
first systems to go out were extremely
simple means most of them didn't even
have a back-end database it was like a
GCS but after a while we started to get
into bigger services but those that were
completely independent then you start
introducing a dependency layer so now
you have multiple systems trying to go
live at the same time so we did it slow
we with the goal of accelerating closely
towards the end right because you start
to gain momentum ones confidence builds
from the deployment so our migration
actually looked like almost no work done
within the first three months because we
were focused on the learnings and the
migration very very minimal services
migrated over the next two months
because we were getting our confidence
and understanding how everything works
on stage and then all of a sudden you
start seeing you know high scale
services just ramping up really quickly
and all of that happened within the last
two maybe three months and finally train
plan and prepare the reason why I'm
calling this out is separate the
artificial pressure of learning from
execution rate as an engineer you know
this when you are told to practically
you are on the go or you're being asked
to devote deliver something that's brand
new it creates this artificial pressure
of I need to do two things at the same
time so we just set it up in a way that
it took that pressure off the teams were
able to focus on learning and training
first and then when they were ready to
go they were able to execute and finally
from the people in process side what are
the things you should do I think this is
very very like kind of you know what we
covered in in the doens is like don't
start in a vacuum so you should align on
overall vision and goals for GCP
migration you know gaps in understanding
like from it has to be topped down as
well a bottoms up like if the engineer
who is actually working on the migration
doesn't align to what the vision of the
companies to why big GCP and where the
migration is going that leads to issues
and conflicts unnecessarily and it will
delay your migration so then alignment
across top down bottoms up is really
really important
establish a migration PMO this may sound
like a really really old school term PMO
but project management office does help
when you are doing a large migration
with multiple work streams with so many
different stakeholders involved and you
know absolutely identify the right
stakeholders both from the Google side
as well as from you know from the unity
side like this really really important
identify clear owners because
responsibility and accountability again
a very old school to Emre see like who's
responsible who's accountable for
success of that work stream that is
really important to really important
identify the fourth one is I think the
one that is really close to my heart
which is set realistic migration goal
like aspiration versus reality like we
keep talking about
yes let's use this migration to do
something dramatic let's you know your
entire stack will change something like
will change drastically versus let's be
real and what can be achieved in the six
months seven months or one year of
migration that you're going to do it so
this alignment is really really
important and you as a company needs to
take a call and what is the realistic
goals establish and track milestones I
think you know we think talked about and
I'm not going to into the details again
because you don't have so much time but
you know have proper tracking and make
sure that you're looking at it on a
weekly bi-weekly monthly cadence
prioritize for risk issues and features
and this goes back to the slide where we
talked about all the feature requests
that unity had like please identify what
is p 0 and P ones for you what is P 2
and P 3 and can wait for 6 months 1 year
please do try to actively identified it
always works better both for Google and
the customer if we have a prioritized
list and on the last point when do you
want to you know this is yeah this is
the one I really want to hammer home
because a lot of a lot of you are gonna
treat a migration as a project that
needs to be done but it's a unique event
and it's an important event it actually
sets the stage for your company and it's
not gonna happen without your people
it's not gonna happen without your
engineers so celebrate success but we
talked about people process technology
quite a bit but if you think of it in
terms of people planning an empowerment
you're gonna get the right technology as
a byproduct of that but if you focus on
letting your smart engineers be
empowered and then get out of the way
and focus instead on how you can unblock
them and how you can help them get to
the right kind of tracking and
milestones they're gonna get the right
results for you deadlines are never the
focus the goals and the vision are and
that's it for us
[Music]
you